Minecraft Steve in competitive smash is
completely broken in every sense of the
word and when I say broken I mean he's
legitimately ruined the game for so many
people that for the first time he's
being banned in a lot of regional
tournaments here's why
all right if Minecraft Steve ruins your
day then our merch might make it better
we've got a whole new range of carefully
crafted Esports apparel including my
absolute favorite the touchgrass hoodie
and it goes pretty well with touching
actual grass trust me so Steve from
Minecraft was added to smash in October
2020 and his time so far has not gone as
smoothly as other additions to the game
we did a video in July last year about
the smash Community getting wound up by
Steve in competitive play he was just
too strong his ability to throw up
protective blocks his Minecart side
special his down air Anvil his diamond
tools his TNT down special and gigantic
magma block with just some of his kit
that made him so frustrating to play
against
down throw jab jab jab jab jab jab jab
Jab
right now
this is no dude what in the world is
this at the time there was some muted
calls for him to be banned but nothing
too widespread just this past week
though that all changed why well the
short answer is he has a game destroying
glitch it's called pmlg aka the ability
to ignore hit stuns these clips from
Connor carried on Twitter were among the
first to show the exploit in action he
credited DARS M9 for its Discovery this
was soon followed by a detailed
explanation from exedo on how to perform
the exploit using a glitch to create a
phantom block before being hit by a move
that doesn't result in Tumble will let
Steve recover from an attack before the
attack animation of his opponent has
ended essentially Steve can use this
glitch to escape any combo and then
perform combos of his own which his
opponent has no ability to counter even
opponent does manage to hit Steve at low
percentages which in itself is an
achievement the bug actually punishes
them for it now nobody likes to throw
around the ban word lightly if there is
a way to deal with these kind of
glitches without having to remove an
entire character from the game most
people would prefer that option but part
of the issue here is that Nintendo
ceased all balance support for Smash
Bros ultimate at the end of 2021 that
means no hotfix is on the way help isn't
coming in the same way it would if this
happened in another esport smash data
analyst Barnard's Loop wrote a twit
longer arguing for a specific Tech ban
saying lower level players are unlikely
to use this glitch and high level
players wouldn't try it while under
constant tournament diligence so
therefore a ban on only the glitch
itself would be relatively easy to
enforce but a lot of people disagree
with this especially given the
difficulty of monitoring online events
that require time-consuming VOD reviews
to enforce move specific bands like this
many felt the only option here was a
total ban on Steve in tournaments and at
the end of February those fans began
rolling in one after the other
tournament organizers across the US
deemed the exploit too much to allow
Steve as a choice for competitors even
Pros weighed in on why these bands are
needed this technique absolutely needs
to be banned like 100 and if you for
some reason don't think this technique
should be banned I really think that
means you should ban Steve dang it man
my whole scene's dying
My Scene Dad it's because of Steve
oh wow we should have banned him like
bro like just do it the number of U.S
states which had seen partial or total
bands of Steve grew in the following
days it was a question that every
Regional smash Community had to Grapple
with it felt like it all came to a head
a week ago when hungrybox announced
Steve had been officially banned at his
coinbox event for the foreseeable future
and so I would like to announce that
until further notice
the coin box will be banning Steve
from all future Ultimate Events we go
into this thinking that this is what the
right call is and something that has
been long overdue and I think pmlg
was the straw that really broke the
camel's back hungrybox was Keen in his
video to let everyone know that
ultimately bounds of this nature are up
to the discretion of individuals regions
and tournament organizers there's no
unifying rules set for smash but at the
same time there's no smoke without fire
it's safe to say that if dozens of
smaller tournaments are removing Steve
from the pool including the influential
coin box will likely see Mages follow
suit and despite the tournament bans the
debate is far from over here there's
still going to be people that say the
glitch isn't prevalent enough or that we
don't really know how it will affect the
scene essentially that this is all a bit
too hasty and while they may be Merit to
that most TOS are simply Banning him out
of an abundance of caution they don't
want to risk him and this glitch
completely wrecking their event and you
can't really blame them it's not like
the community hasn't been burned by
something like this before back in 2012
there was a temporary blanket ban on
Meta Knight in competitive brawl owing
to his absurd speed and aerial abilities
which completely invalidated most of the
cast some are pointing to that and
saying Meta Knight was far more dominant
than Steve was or even is right now with
this glitch but Pro Player Larry lure
who played some Meta Knight back on
brawl firmly disagrees one of the
arguments I know people are going to
make is that Steve's results aren't
nearly as dominant as midnights was in
bra and my explanation to this is that's
true and I don't think it will ever be
that way for two reasons the first one
is that Steve was not part of the base
game roster I think if he was people
would more immediately know how
overpowered he was and the vast majority
of players would be using him as a main
or secondary similar to Mennonite the
second one is that most of the top top
players do not use him and don't want to
regardless of how overpowered you feel
that I was in Brawl the fact of the
matter is the majority of the players
getting results with him at major events
were talented players ultimately these
kind of bands give the competitive scene
some time and breathing room to assess
the real danger that this kind of glitch
represents sure many people have already
made their minds up and are happy to see
the Steve bands and as we've seen in
this video there's certainly a case for
that but that doesn't necessarily mean
we'll never see him again there are
still tournaments out there that are
going to allow him and even some that
might revert their ban if they see data
that suggests perhaps he's not as much
of a threat to the competitive Integrity
as they first thought as frustrating as
this all is it comes part and parcel
with a game that's no longer receiving
balance updates and Steve a broken
character with a game-shattering bug is
simply the latest victim of this reality
it's just funny to me that like
the the the character that's causing all
this like chaos and argument and debate
isn't some like you know demon from some
like crazy Fantasy game it's just Steve
from Minecraft this is the it was a
character that was never really meant to
fight he was never even really meant to
be a character he was just you know the
default skin if you enjoy digging and
building